spartan  ah we're in range of ignovus the  devourer  so named because  well he's a brute so you can probably  guess dangerous doesn't begin to  describe this guy don't turn your back  on him  [Music]  disappoint me spartan this skill was no  challenge  we're in range of ignovus the devourer  so named because  well he's a brood so  dangerous doesn't begin to describe this  guy  but we're not finished yet get the crew  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  ah  we're in range of ignovus the devourer  so named because  well he's a brute so you can probably  guess  dangerous doesn't begin to describe this  guy don't turn your back on him  uh  uh  oh  here  suckers  [Music]  oh  target elimination confirmed but we're  not out of the woods yet finish up the  squad  [Music]  um  [Applause]  the devourer is no more and if his  dossier is accurate that's a very very  good thing  i'm grossed out just thinking about it  so i'm gonna stop thinking about it  great work chief